like a team the sniper she is on nice
and close behind us the Ross Ice Shelf
team has traveled about 30 miles and
they're facing the most dangerous part
of their Traverse we just want to make
sure that everybody's capable should the
worst possible case happen the shear
zone looks like a safe patch of snow but
like Mount Erebus it's full of hidden
crevasses first laughing benign as it
looks is a lot going on one side we've
got sort of McMurdo ice shelf and the
other is the Ross Ice Shelf that's weird
two large kind of ice masses are coming
together much like a river comes
together and the reason it's called a
shear zone is because there's kind of a
shearing effect between the two so it's
quite an active area interesting the
shear zionists an intimidating area
around about six or so kilometers that's
have number of significantly large
professors in them we know that there's
a route through there we really reduce
that speed down even further so that
we're a hundred percent xual what we're
driving on is is good to drive across
we're just gonna reverse rescue proceed
with caution
fingers crossed crossing the shear zone
should take a few hours but Tom and Rob
have been preparing for it for weeks
so this is the radar boom for Pb 100 and
we'll be fitting a GPR unit
ground-penetrating radar and we'll be
able to see on the monitor
and when we're approaching crevasses and
that'll enable us to not drive into them
state-of-the-art technology real key
piece of this whole project for this
year and going into the future as well
so just got to get it up and running the
boom stretches 24 feet ahead and
connects to a screen that shows ice
composition up to 49 feet deep bends in
the lines indicate empty space under the
snow some of the crevasses through here
would literally swallow this whole
vehicle in probably the two trailers
behind it so if we hadn't looked at the
radar imagery and we actually just
carried on dropped into a crevasse it
would probably be all over